this movie first started I was like okay
so this might actually be the closest
thing to a live-action South Park we
might get and the feeling didn't stick
around for too long but at first I was
like well I've actually South Park all
right cool
[Music]
good boys so good boys is a raunchy
comedy starring a trio of middle
schoolers they get into a tangled web of
plot that go on an adventure in which
the end game is the most important thing
they will do in their lives that's right
at least one of them is gonna kiss a
girl the other two I mean their support
they're cool you know friends stick
together friends run across freeway
traffic together and I get a kick out of
those raunchy comedies get a kick out of
you know kids being kind of [ __ ] up
because they are I know we all want to
believe like now kids are you know
they're rated G all the time when
parents aren't there it's not true this
really celebrates that it goes a little
over the top but it's supposed to
because what I like about this this
concept and some of the execution in
this movie with the concept is that
these kids are old enough to think
through the smartest adults ever not
smart enough to know that they're really
naive about a lot of things so when it
comes to the logistics of looking up
porn on the internet or finding sex toys
they don't really know what they're
looking at I know that kind of cracks me
up back in my day we would just call one
of those nine hundred sex lines actually
did that it came up on the phone belt
I got in so much trouble it's true story
it's real and as enjoyable as that was
for me it kind of wore thin and a point
all right what are we doing where are we
going we're just we're doing things in
the end you felt like you know they're
doing things because the filmmakers were
like well it's fun to have 12 year olds
do really raunchy things or say raunchy
things and be foul-mouthed little shits
but like good-hearted kids like they're
not bad they're good kids and it's a fun
premise and the point of the movie
actually starts to rear its head and the
last act we're talking near the end of
the movie one of the three endings of
this movie has it actually does deal
with the fact that it's a coming-of-age
story and you know things change and
childhood logistics and friends circles
they start to alter and change and you
have to be cool with that it was like
$0.99 super bad it was like someone had
a concept of taking super bad and making
them younger and after that concept it's
like I don't know how we're gonna do it
but
like to do it funny with the raunch
comedy is getting younger and younger
with the cast like you got super bad and
then alright now they've got good boys I
can't wait for the reboot
look who's talking [ __ ] that'll happen
eventually kind of wanted to happen now
actually pretty funny actually the kids
were really endearing I really liked all
of them all three of them I thought they
worked well together and the movie
pretty regularly had chuckles no belly
laughs but chuckles it was one saying
that actually cracked me up it's the
funniest scene in the movie involves the
freeway scene but in the end I felt like
this movie had a great crew like a great
group of friends that worked well
together and a great premise with very
little direction when I was watching the
movie I was like this is a first-time
director I promise you and I am D beed
he's done some TV work but yeah for
feature film first time director for
feature film and it's show just like
when you're watching the movie you just
you see that it's a great concept but
the direction was a little messy and in
the end I walked out of this movie going
it have been a better time if I were
drunk ya know the party I will say the
movies a little uneven and how mature
the kids are and I feel like the writers
wrote a couple things in here just so
they don't take heat on Twitter there's
one thing in particular this is a good
example of how they're naive 99% of the
time and in this one time it's like
that's something an adult should have
said in this movie not a kid there's
this line in the movie where this
douchebag frat boy drug dealers they're
trying to get drugs from him and for
this other person and this dude was like
if she wants and she can go ahead and
suck my dick and the main kick goes to
all the time she should be doing that as
if she gives consent which first of all
kid you're right I absolutely agree with
you and I want to stress right now
consent is important but him saying that
was weirdly out of place just into
general theme of the movie for his
character like this is a kid who he
doesn't know how to open a childproof
bottle when looking how to kiss online
doesn't know where to start when seeing
porn online doesn't really know the
logistics of what he's actually watching
when he finds sex toys doesn't
understand what they are but when a frat
boy says that his first thing that he
naturally jumps to has got to address
consent what it felt like it was either
the writer or director were like okay
this movie is about a kid whose entire
motivation is he's going to go to this
party to kiss the girls
we have to stress to the audience that
he does understand the logistics of
consent
could you imagine the backlash we might
get online on social media if we don't
address that oh man and that's what it
felt like it felt like a line a
throwaway line in the movie for
real-world damage controller at least to
avoid backlash I don't know it still
that's me like a sore thumb because it
wasn't a moment for the characters in
the movie it was a moment where they
might as well have turned to the camera
and given us a lesson in the real world
because it's very important there is a
bigger conversation to have here and
that is our writers directors our
comedies free to do what they want to do
or do they have to have little throwaway
lines and things in their movies so
people can go down the checklist and be
like okay checked all the boxes alright
they've fully Illustrated that they're
not problematic so it's fine so to be
clear I'm not talking about it's not a
conversation about consent it's a
conversation about the natural flow of
comedy and writing and at a point
wouldn't you people put things in movies
that don't make sense for the movie or
the characters but they have to to avoid
backlash and is that good for comedy
like I don't think that's good for
comedy to be honest with you sometimes I
feel like I've woken up in the world of
demolition man and it's [ __ ] weird I
don't know I feel like that's a
conversation worth having now so I guess
we'll have it here so good boys have you
seen it why should you think about it
and what do you think about what I just
said but at what point do the thought
police of Twitter just now make it to
where comedy can't be comedy anymore and
are we getting there I think it's we're
talking about so let's talk about in the
comments section whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more keep it civil down there that's
all I ask
[Music]